ANNOUNCER:
Ladies and gentlemen,
the 45th and final
President of the United States.
(cheers and applause)
Why?
Thank you.
First, I want to comment
on the passing
of one of my own
personal heroes,
Playboy founder, Hugh Hefner.
That guy was my kind
of feminist:
A man who loved boobs.
So much.
Hef, I'll see you
in pervert heaven,
which is regular-people hell.
Can you tell us any more details
about your tax plan?
My tax plan
is to never pay taxes.
Oh, you mean the government one?
No, I'm not gonna read that.
Why can't your party pass a
health care bill?
Because football players,
national anthem, kneeling.
Where's the outrage?
-You-you didn't answer
the question. -Excuse me.
Pointing out that I didn't
answer the question
is disrespectful to our flag.
I mean, look at her.
Isn't she beautiful?
So many stars.
If she wasn't my flag,
I'd be dating her.
And that's why tonight's theme
is flag.
Isn't it hypocritical
for Jared and Ivanka
to use personal e-mail
for official business
-when you criticized
Hillary Clinton... -♪ Oh, say ♪
♪ Can you see? ♪
♪ By the lawn's ♪
♪ Pearly whites ♪
Are you singing
the national anthem
to avoid answering the question?
♪ What so loudly we wailed ♪
♪ And the ramparts ♪
♪ Ram-parting ♪
Do you not know the words?
Quiet, honey.
If words mattered, I wouldn't be
president right now.
♪ And the rocket's red bears ♪
♪ Uh, proof in the night ♪
♪ That the bag ♪
♪ Lilith Fair ♪
How can you not know
the national anthem?
-Did you say "bag Lilith Fair"?
-Shut up. Shut up.
I'm honoring the flag I never
fought for.
Can you at least tell us
why it took you so long
to send help to Puerto Rico?
You can't ask me
about another country
when I'm singing
the American anthem.
Puerto Ricans are
American citizens.
Excuse me.
♪ Excuse me ♪
♪ E-Excuse me ♪
♪ Excu-ooh-ooh, ooh-ooh ♪
♪ Oohs me ♪
I mean, you are being
disrespectful, sir.
Can you answer our questions?
♪ I'm the ♪
♪ Pre-e-es-i-dent... ♪
(cheering and applause)
♪ Can you be-li-eve it? ♪
Let's roll.